back to las vegas now vegas entertainer
terry spader star of who's that dummy
now over at new york new york is
inviting you to his very special after
party terry fader after hours will be a
monthly performance at the bar at times
square after his stage show and guess
who's here to tell us more
it's terry fader and winston i'm here
what's up winston how are you i'm doing
really good it's it's it's a little hot
for you humans but us turtles are used
to it listen do you have any suggestions
how to get in your show and stay there
i like that i like that all right now
let's let's talk about after parties
what what is your ideal after party how
do you after party well you know i i
came up with this idea when i was uh at
the mirage and i just i love my show
yeah i do too we do too i'm the star of
the show yes he is the star of the show
no doubt about that but um but in my
show i only do a couple of songs where i
do the full length my show moves very
quickly there's a lot of humor there's
there and i do i do clips of songs and i
really missed i was in a band for 20
years uh before i before i went on
america's got talent and uh and so i i i
just missed it and so i i asked the
people of the mirage i said is it okay
if i go down to the bar and sing after
my show and they said you'd do that and
i said i would love to yeah like you're
not tired so we started doing that and
and so i asked him when i moved over to
new york new york i said do you mind if
i go and and do and they said you do
that i said i would love to so we just
get there with a piano player and we
take requests and and i sing and i think
no you don't no what yeah i'll see
i'm not going to be there no winston's
feeling left out you're not going to sue
he's feeling left out because he's not a
part of the after show party i know i'm
the star of the other show well you are
the star of the other show but i get to
be the star of this one right because i
can sing no you can't he can't sing
without me yes i can but so it gives me
a chance to do all these different
impressions and i get to do the
full-length songs and if you and if you
uh the the folks out there watching if
you guys go to my socials you know my
youtube uh once a week on youtube and
facebook i release a full song and
winston yeah i do a lot of those i did a
bg song a little while back yeah and
then um this week is going to be uh
stevie wonder oh we're hearing a little
bit right now
this week
this week
i actually have a stevie wonder puppet
and stevie is going to be singing a song
tomorrow we're going to we release it on
wednesdays on my youtube channel and on
my facebook on thursdays okay so on
thursday is the next after party show so
tell everybody what they can expect at
the after party well you don't have to
come to my uh my show
who's the dummy now up in the uh liberty
loft which but we hope you do i mean
that you get to come see the show and i
have seen it it's so good
just great i loved it i loved everything
so but then we move right down i take
about 15 minutes to change my clothes go
down i get a bottle of water and i might
even have an adult alcohol i was going
to say just a bottle of water huh i do i
do like to do that occasionally i don't
do that in my regular show but when i'm
doing the after show i might have a jack
and coke or something who knows or maybe
one of those beers that we were talking
about we've got some local craft beers
he's taking a stick back home and then i
just sit there for about an hour hour
and a half and sing and i'm trying to to
see if we can get some of the local
entertainers
i just made a uh it's kind of an
impromptu special appearance with
michael grimm he was over at the
sterling club and uh and michael and i
right down the street yeah just down the
street and um and so so i'm hoping that
we can do the same thing and get some
get some special i had darcy lynn farmer
who won america's got talent a few years
ago
and she joined me the last time i don't
know if anybody's going to join me this
time but if not it's just going to be me
um i won't be there i i mean i i can i
can join you i can you can you you're
welcome to come out and join me
i think my assistant marina is going to
be singing we did we did an elton john
song what was the one okay
what was it do it
cold heart yes and she did the uh is it
do it do a leap do a lip do a lipa do a
lipa she did the do a leap apart and so
i told her i said bone up on that
because you're gonna have to come up and
sing with me so
yes we do stuff from uh classic modern
and i do all of them are impressions so
i'll do that richard marks and i'll do
ed sheeran and then i'll do elvis
presley and i'll do nat king cole and
and it's just and it's just a lot of fun
what can't you do terry that's the
question that is so cool thank you
winston well he can't do me that's for
sure yeah sure at least not during that
show right
all right well that's terry fader after
hours of monthly performance featuring
special guests at the bar at times
square at new york new york performances
will happen immediately following
performances on stage of his
award-winning show terry fader who's the
dummy now jillian i'll send it to you
always so much fun all right just